ma bella tutti ragazzi è benvenuta
questo video sono fra vj oggi siamo sul
videogioco che ha un menù talmente
colorato che potreste vomitare
arcobaleni c'è poco un menù
ecco perfetto il come potete vedere il
colore predominante e l'arancione os
fori scelte siano sul web the terrorist
perché ragazzi continua nonostante gli
anni passano calcetti continua a fare
gli work ma per carità di dio va bene
c'è però per dire la [ __ ] ogni tanto
dove parlo io poi è fantastico ragazzi
se consumati a terra rispecchia hanno
fatto anche work the terrorist che
sarebbe maltratta al terrorista è
veramente aspetto solo al momento in cui
faranno white fa vj prova tutti i dodici
modi per fermare il terrorista play
vediamo se riusciamo a fare sta roba è
proprio così senza neanche una intro mi
chiamano sta facendo a pugnetta presenti
zio alla la smettesse di fatti le
pugnette per cortesia perfetto cos'è sta
roba
ecco il primo attrezzo questa cosa fa
malissimo preferirei la morte preferirei
decisamente la morte però almeno è sugli
hamburger non credo serva il ketchup
allora questo punto poi non lo so e fa
bene non ha mai non era violento la per
carità di dio era solo un modo
alternativo per cucinare gli hamburger
cioè la fine che deve arrivare da
qualche parte no a game
facciamo ancora ma
nemmeno conta uno di 12 perfetto dove
tra l'altro ci sta un terrorista che non
riesce a far partire un cazzo ci sono io
qua bello bello con l'iphone ha tanto
posso ucciderlo con l'iphone
questo gioca vale ma che cazzo ne frega
fa usa l'iphone uccidilo a serviva
soltanto per dirti che te lo puoi
scaricare con me non me ne frega un pene
quindi va bene lo stesso con la sedia ma
ti diceva puoi scaricare il gioco anche
con le sedie è successo è la madonna
pronta viola e vabbè vabbè mi hanno
sbagliate hitler non è stato ucciso con
un'arma da fuoco e stato ucciso con le
sedie 2016 muovermi di distruzioni di
massa ovvero le sedi e voi non lo sapete
ragazzi ma le sedie sono veramente
cattive persone ne mancano 10 era che la
sono ancora curioso di capire che
diavolo su che cos'è sta roba questo
quadro nella torre tipo quella degli
aerei se non sbaglio stacca scan aereo
rega questo è un cecchino il gatto è una
specie vabbè ma cos'è sta roba è una
luce attira gatti
penso che la chiesa che quanto quanto 3
questo gioco santo gesù con quali
effetti sonori all'avanguardia proprio
di si sente proprio l'urlo di
disperazione di quest'uomo ho cliccato
la torre pensavo mi scendesse giunti
vuol aereo qualsiasi cosa fa un cecchino
remi chiari serviva perciò per attirare
un cazzo di gatto la cassetta degli
attrezzi
noi siamo in un catene fatemi capire che
cosa ci sta a fare una cassetta degli
attrezzi nei due giorni che mira non si
staccasse tanto lui non si lamenta mai
il togato di terrorista lui non urla va
bene così sempre meglio questo che le 18
del gatto e per carità di dio così star
cavatappi lo zelo tripoli è quello
colori non è un tappo però comunque
complimenti per le mutande frate contro
eva
se posso fare una considerazione se me
lo permettete in tutto questo poteva
andargli molto peggio messa se ci fosse
stato rocco al posto del cane ma tanto
peggio è andata ancora bene possiamo
fare tipo il combi al tombino ovviamente
che lo spingo dentro questa roba ci
aveva azzeccato il cazzo i ragazzi non
ci posso credere cioè pazzesca starò
questa faccenda perché sembra una papera
spiegano
sto dando fuoco a hitler va bene questo
gioco ha un senso perfetto la bottiglia
comunque che lui continua bene niente
fosse
ok colpo di grazia 10 6 orazzo stesso
fran incredibile cazzo non pensavo
potessi genere anche tu zio non perchè
non lo fai mai bene tu cosa che manca
regalati pone a questo mi chiama come
fai a sollevare quella roba lì zero
spiega anche scusato giustamente non ci
avevo pensato dove lui non si accorge
ovviamente di niente di tutto questo e
per carità di dio non si sa mai che alzi
in attimo lo sguardo ma magari un
attimino prima vabbè non è un problema
chi ha delle cose sono chiavi
cos'è sta roba matias anno sono le prese
della corrente
celle l i morsetti come funzionali in
attacco 1 e poi lascio gli attacchi a
posso fare perché non ha detto niente
va beh guarda il lato positivo zio
radiografia gratis
ma perché i capezzoli perché c'è i
capezzoli insanguinati che cosa c'entra
9 su 12 me ne mancano tre era che non sa
che cosa devo fare riuscirò a trovarli
c'è scusa con la k con l'arma sua
veramente girati zio che se non riesco
perfezione ce l'ho fatta la freccia
perfetto non si usano così le armi
comunque si usa ecco così si usa
stavo dicendo però magari fai un head
shot niente a posto lui mi legge nel
pensiero ragazzi ne mancano due ragazze
o non le vedono se anche perché l'altro
la la cappa non lo potevi prendere
sempre solo quando si gira quindi magari
puoi prendere qualcos'altro tipo di
guasto alla pompa a perfetto quindi li
hanno infilare proprio copione pivot a
non è proprio così
ecco questo è più o meno il concetto di
pompa solo po strano cene se il frate si
è diventato uno snow relax c'è
ok da adesso in avanti non voglio più
incontrare snor l'ex per strada neanche
in pokémon gol
a proposito di pokemon gozzi io ma
invece di usare sto coso cerca i pokémon
siamo in centro almeno qualcosa dovresti
trovando quanto odio quando alla fine io
sempre così e quando arrivò alla fine di
sti giochi sempre o non trova mai il
pezzo finale non so perché ho cazzo
l'orologio cioè non ero è il timer che
orologio lui guarda guarda allora sulla
bomba mi scusi che ora sono cinque e
mezzo e mi fai cliccare perfetto lo
sapevo che ci aveva detto lui
questo fa male questo fa decisamente
male anche questo è così che centrava
qualcosa l'omino michelin altro io sono
rimasto così a terra rimarrò così per il
resto la mia vita è stato stupendo
finito ho vinto del sito di shin chan
animazione niente proprio so neanche
neanche la scritta hai vinto c'è ormai
una gioia non c'è niente [ __ ]
almeno la scritta di merda puoi finire
così allora sentite faceva una roba su
stessa roba su google
scegli una categoria nomi
che figata ma veramente tu devi
indovinare quali di queste categorie
google trova 9 geniale bellissimo lo
farò la prossima volta bellissimo ho
scoperto per casi simo cliccato un gioco
a caso semplicemente è una roba che c'è
ancora il gioco del terrorista ma
[ __ ] facciamo tipo che ne so i
nomi di nuovo ronald mcdonald sicuro è
infatti lo sapevo non al meglio il
secondo risultato fantastico
non me lo voglio spoilerare bellissimo
non lo so l'ho trovato a caso però mi
piace sta roba di aver trovato un gioco
a caso così allora che solis spero che
viene sia piaciuto ha lasciato un bel
commento mi piace anche per ronald
mcdonald che comparso alla cazzo di cane
in questo video se e solo se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi ci dividiamo
porta di quella ladra [ __ ] dei
ragazzi